Cameron Diaz plays a lazy teacher who
does nothing but show her kids movies
all day this movie should be called good
teacher bad teachers directed by Jake
Kasdan who also directed zero effect
Orange County and walk hard a Dewey Cox
story says Cameron Diaz Jason Segel
Justin Timberlake and Phyllis Smith
Cameron Diaz plays someone who's
basically a gold digger she was dating
somebody because you know he was really
rich and everything and when he dumps
her she doesn't really have any
prospects she has to go back to this
teaching job she doesn't want to be at
she basically just shows her kids movies
all day and she's rude to everyone Jason
Segel plays a gym teacher kind of has a
thing for her he's pretty funny and
justin timberlake is a sub who moves
into the area or whatever and starts
teaching there and Cameron Diaz starts
to get the idea that if she can impress
him and get with him because his
family's rich she starts this rivalry
with a spello teacher played by Lucy
punch who also likes Justin Timberlake
she gets all these crazy ideas and
schemes to try to make her life better I
found this movie I thought it was a lot
of fun I didn't really know what to
expect this movie because the trailers
were funny the pacing of the film is
excellent it never drags I think one of
the best parts of this movie is the
rivalry between Cameron Diaz and Lucy
punches character that is a really well
realized they both like the same guy
they both start competing to be better
teachers the way they plan for each
other it was just great I've always
liked Cameron Diaz and I think that
people unfairly basher and I think that
people bash her just because it's easy
to bash her that's one of the things I
really was starting to load when people
just make fun of someone just because
everyone else does because it's easy to
it's hard sometimes to say you don't
like something when everyone else likes
it and it's easy to say I don't like
this actor or actress because everyone
else does that too I like Cameron Diaz
and I think she's a talented actress and
I do think she's pretty and I think
she's good in this movie that's my
opinion on that Jason Segel is also
pretty funny in the movie too and he has
they have a good relationship her and
his character I also Phyllis Smith as
the friend of Cameron Diaz his character
at school she was really funny in this
poufy Justin Timberlake in this film he
wasn't bad or anything I mean I thought
he was really good in the social network
but something about is for
for months was fake and I think it was
because his character I think they were
just going purposely going for a very
over-the-top kind of like ah like goody
two-shoes kind of character you know I
didn't really have a problem with his
performance at all I like Justin
Timberlake one of the biggest issues I
have this film is the fact that Cameron
Diaz is a teacher she hates being a
teacher she's terrible at being a
teacher she doesn't follow the
curriculum to be a teacher you have to
go through at least I think four years
of college I mean one of my best friends
is an art teacher he had to go to
college for four years
you can't just apply to be a teacher you
have to I mean why how in the world is
she a teacher why is she a teacher
because you're usually a sub before
you're a teacher you had to prove that
you can be a good teacher it's just it
doesn't make any sense that someone who
hates their job that much and is so bad
at it would be able to keep it and would
actually do it and go through four years
of college you know it's kind of strange
especially since she's the kind of
person to go from man to man just
looking for someone who's rich why would
she be a teacher it doesn't make sense
that's my biggest problem with the movie
it's a really flawed area but the thing
is you don't really suppose to pay
attention to that you're kind of
supposed to enjoy the movie but that
sense of the film is really really
flawed it didn't bother my enjoyment of
the film I just kind of noticed it was
like hey you know that makes no sense
and also some of the morals of the movie
in regards to what you can do and get
away with it seemed a little odd they
were preaching it it just seemed like
they were kind of saying you can do bad
stuff and get away with it and it's okay
if you get away with it but still the
point of this movie is to have a silly
fun time and it does that very well I
think one of the best things about this
movie is the characters are very well
realized and they all interact with each
other very well they all have good
chemistry and those are really important
things for a comedy so I'm going to get
bad teacher three out of four stars it's
a fun silly enjoyable movie it's nothing
remarkable it does have some strange
underlying problems and issues but with
a movie like this you're not really
supposed to focus on that so if you have
a chance to see bad teacher you might
enjoy it
Oh